trump está convocando a la marcha safe
américa a partir de las 7 de la mañana
ya la gente podrá acercarse a la parte
trasera de la casa blanca donde convocó
la marcha a las 11 de la mañana dará un
discurso también hay marchas en la plaza
fluida plaza también en el capitolio y
en la plaza
blacklight marley ya estarán los
simpatizantes de donald trump al
respecto a la alcaldesa de la ciudad
muriel bowser le ha pedido a los
ciudadanos que por favor no salgan a
manifestar su rechazo en contra de un
otro precisamente para evitar la
violencia recordemos que la marcha
pasada hubo 33 arrestos y ya el líder de
el grupo el movimiento proárbol
simpatizante de trump había sido
arrestado precisamente por cargar
munición con él entonces la ciudad va a
estar completamente paralizada en el
centro de la ciudad precisamente para
evitar la violencia
cristóbal y cuéntenos a qué hora
comienza la sesión de certificación de
la elección presidencial en el congreso
y cómo es este proceso
empieza a la una de la tarde hora de
washington cuando las dos cámaras tanto
el senado como la cámara de
representantes se reúnen en el mismo
lugar para contar los votos electorales
pero como ya sabemos 12 senadores y
cerca de 140 representantes a la cámara
republicanos van a objetar estos
resultados esto lo que lo que significa
es que tras la objeción el senado y la
cámara vuelven a separarse y votan si
aceptan o no la objeción de estos
congresistas la cámara de representantes
es de mayoría demócrata eso quiere decir
que lo más probable es que no acepten
objeción y el senado pues también ha
dicho aunque republicano que tampoco
aceptará la objeción esto quiere decir
que no no va a tener futuro estas
objeciones las dos cámaras se reunirán
nuevamente y aceptarán después del
conteo pues la certificación del nuevo
presidente de eeuu joe biden
cerca de las 5 o 6 de la tarde
conoceremos entonces la decisión final
de tanto republicano
republicanos y demócratas en la cámara
representantes y en